sandra let's bring in chad wolf former
acting dhs secretary under president
trump chad welcome
so what's the practical impact of this
supreme court ruling to the men and
women on the front lines at our southern
border so look this is a disappointing
ruling and why is it disappointing
because the program worked and not only
do border patrol agents and other law
enforcement support the program i think
most americans support the program as
well we used it in 2019 and 2020 and we
saw results it helps not only secure
that border but it absolutely helps
control
the asylum process and it gets those
that need asylum protections quicker
access to those protections instead what
you have today is a catch and release
system that allows these individuals
into the country for years at a time so
i think the practical effect is that the
cartels the smugglers and the
traffickers are going to use this court
decision a decision that was you know
pushed by the biden administration to
again attract and lure more individuals
to come to the united states and what
they'll sell them on is to say there is
now zero chance that you're going to be
put into mpp or the remaining mexico
program there's going to be almost 100
chance that you're going to get released
into the united states we have brand new
reaction from texas governor greg abbott
let's put it on the screen quote the
supreme court's decision upholding dhs's
termination of the remain in mexico
policy will only embolden the bide
administration's open border policies
reinstating and fully enforcing remain
in mexico would deter thousands more
migrants from making that deadly trek
and president biden should take that
simple step to secure the border because
because it is the only humane thing to
do
it's obviously been a heartbreaking week
in the state of texas with migrants and
in a very difficult at least year and a
half yeah absolutely i think it's
important to remember look the court's
decision doesn't tell dhs that they must
remove or eliminate the program it's
still up to the bind administration they
still have the choice to implement this
program or not to improve it to make it
better but at the end of the day look
they're making a number of decisions i
think most americans are throwing their
hands up and saying why are you doing
this why are you allowing the situation
at the border to remain out of control
and every month we see the illegal
apprehension numbers get worse and worse
and worse and so the question is if you
don't want mpp
what else do you want in its place what
other program or procedures are you
going to put in place to control the
situation on the border and i've said
this before the cartels want one thing
and that's predictability to run their
businesses and the bite administration
is giving them that one thing the
predictability from day one which is
they're not putting any new measures in
place to deter the illegal behavior
instead they throw their hands up and
they say well this is just how it is and
most americans are just going to have to
accept this and that's just the wrong
strategy it's the wrong approach you're
not putting america first you're putting
them last when you do that do you think
the supreme court in effect is saying to
the white house and congress like sit
down and come up with a plan
well i think so again they didn't rule
on the merits of mpp in fact as you read
the opinion and the majority says
dhs actually has legal authority to do
this congress gave them the authority to
do this uh the question is whether they
could they could rescind the program or
not and so they obviously have that
authority now uh but look you can you
can look at congress needing to to make
some changes but the executive branch
and we proved this out in 2019 and 2020
has a lot of authority they just have to
have leadership and will to use that to
make some hard decisions
along that border to control the border
and to deter this illegal behavior and
we just haven't seen any of that
leadership any of that vision laid out
over the past 15 or 16 months instead
it's just open borders and you continue
to see these astronomically high
apprehension numbers that we've never
seen before you had one month back in
march of 2000 when it got over 200 000
illegal apprehensions one month in the
byte administration we have five months
so it just tells you sort of where we're
going and where the trend line is going
nearly out of time but what's the morale
of men and women at our border on the
front line well it's terrible um you
know if you're border patrol agents
you've been you've been asking your
leadership to reinstate remain a mexico
program and so you see the news here
which is the supreme court ruling but
you know that your political leadership
has been against this program from day
one so slowly and surely they've removed
every tool in your tool belt to address
the border crisis the last thing that
you have left is title 42 and they hear
that their political leadership wants to
remove title 42 and that's in the courts
as well and so
you don't have a lot of confidence on
where this is going and there's no light
at the end of the tunnel and that's hard
for these folks who live and breathe uh
who live in these border communities
every day chad wolfe thanks so much for
your time thank you your analysis hi
everyone i'm brian kilmeade i want you
to do me a favor i want you to click to
subscribe to the fox news youtube page
this is the only way that i know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
fox you can get it all here on youtube
so subscribe right now